what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so we're back into it with venom
verse and we haven't done edge have been
averse for a while actually we did the
first one with x-23 the second one was
what swim pool I didn't really enjoy her
too much I figured if we're gonna jump
back into it we're going to do this
awesome story where Ghost Rider becomes
venom and it's super cool so the cool
thing about this is that this actually
picks up with Calvin zabo or Szabo or
however you want to pronounce it also a
guy named mr. Hyde Calvin first appeared
in journey into mystery number 99 and
his initial enemy was actually Thor it
was Donald Blake now what this story
does is it takes a few liberties when it
comes to Calvin's character for the most
part when it comes to these other
realities stories which is to say
stories that take place in different
universes things usually shift based on
what the writers doing it would be a
story like what if deadpool became venom
and then in that story
they basically reveal to us that the
events of secret wars to just never
ended that the Beyonder just showed up
on earth and basically kept earth of
like this 1980 place for a while until
he got bored and then it became 1990s
but it just rests on forever and ever
and ever and ever those are the kind of
things that take place some massive
event that normally would have
transpired in the main Marvel Universe
we have transpired differently and the
result is that that what-if story comes
out of it like what if the Punishers
family hadn't been killed in a part and
instead the punisher just had his family
and things were relatively normal that
of course ended with his family dying
anyway but the fact remains you guys
understand what I'm saying that it
usually just kind of deviates from the
status quo as we know it Calvin
character was a guy who was obsessed
with manipulating hormones more or less
and he had created something called a
hide formula now the hide formula when
he used it on himself basically made him
mr. Hyde and so he was very much
obsessed with like the dr. Jekyll mr.
Hyde mythos and so it made sense when he
took this formula and turned himself
into this massive hulking beast that he
would just call himself mr. Hyde the
result is that what this story seems to
do is it basically takes the events of
journey into mystery number 99 and it
turns them on its head where Calvin had
eventually found employment at a
hospital in the same hospital that
Donald Blake worked at the alternate
persona of Thor that doesn't seem to
have happened and said he just seems to
have gone about his business being a guy
with the high formula experimenting on
people so on and so forth which
ultimately led to him being taken into
shield custody and then transferred to a
secure facility or some kind of a
secured facility now the reason why this
is important is because over the course
of his exist
how they never faced Thor and never
defeated for presumably anyway we're
kind of making that assumption mr. Hyde
had found work with a multitude of
different characters in the old villain
superheroes so on and so forth and it
also takes a lot of the traditional
characters and it basically says where
they were normally good guys
maybe Calvin showed up to them at some
point in time and where they would have
gone down this path of being a good guy
they went down the path of being a bad
guy now what we know here is that this
this attack that's being launched on on
mr. Hyde is being done for a multitude
of reasons for the victims that he
experimented on the family members of
those victims of friends and family that
are trying to get revenge it's one of
these things where a guy who seems to
know everything about everything when it
comes to the villain underworld villains
want to keep him from speaking it's a
classical mob mentality what this
basically gives us is just this massive
assault on how then this group that's
taking them to the driverless prison is
going to be by shield now of course this
also leads into the introduction of octo
Squatch pool now of course what would a
what a story be without just some
ridiculous version of Deadpool this is
basically a version of Deadpool that's
sasquatch it has all the healing factor
of Deadpool and it also has the arms of
Doctor Octopus it's actually kind of
cool it's a weird name but it's kind of
cool I think it's kind of interesting
but again what's really being done here
at least what's being told to us as the
reader anyway that all this is happening
because of the fact that again
Calvin knows all these secrets about the
criminal underworld he knows all these
things you know he's experimented on
people he's tortured people visited
people as to whether his victims whether
it's superheroes who believe they're
doing the right thing whether it is
villains who don't want their secrets
filled out to the world everybody is
trying to take out this caravan of Shila
now of course this reads into the
introduction of Ghost Rider
and this is cool because initially we
don't get an answer as to how this
happened and the other story that we did
in x-23 it was just she was trying to
escape the facility she ran into the
venom Samia and bonded with her and that
was that with death we just pop up with
Ghost Rider on the scene as venom and
it's kind of cool because what this does
is it actually gives us the opposite
version of the ghost runner now this
version is Robbie Reyes and one thing to
keep in mind here is that when it comes
to the difference between Robbie Reyes
and like Danny ketch or Johnny Blaze
Robby ray is is different because Robbie
way is does not possess a true spirit of
vengeance instead he's actually
possessed by a spirit named Eli Moro
who's actually his uncle I think it is
but the idea here is
this version of Ghost Rider instead of
fighting on behalf of the innocent and
punishing the wicked he's just like
punishing all the innocent people that's
basically what he's doing he's
effectively a villain the long and short
of this is that Ghost Rider makes quick
work out of all the shield agents and so
again this is kind of a big deal because
once it's all said and done what ends up
happening is Ghost Rider immediately
ends up routing Calvin and of course the
idea is to basically subdue Calvin now
this is when we get the origin story of
what's been going on here when it came
to the Robbie Reyes ghost rider
character he was really just a victim of
circumstance he was the quintessential
example of the guy who was in the wrong
place at the wrong time essentially his
uncle Eli Morrow was just like this
devil worshiper he was just was crazy
guy eventually his spirit inhabited this
Dodge Charger that Bobby Reyes was
driving and it resulted in Roddy Rae as
basically being bonded with big spirit
of Eli Morrow now the way this
transpired was kind of like this weird
scenario where a couple guys tried to
track down Roddy Rae as you know he
basically bond with the spirit went and
killed a few of the people and that was
really about it
but what the story did in terms of Roddy
Rae is and how it differentiated him
from Johnny Blaze is that Eli Morrow did
not initially present himself as a bad
guy he actually just presented himself
as somebody who was like hey this
neighborhood is bad and there are people
who have tried to harm you and I can
give you the power to make your
neighborhood a better place for your
brother Gabe and for yourself and so on
and so forth and so the result was that
Robbie ray is initially welcomed the
abilities that were given to him by Eli
Morrow and having the powers of a Ghost
Rider the issue with this is that as
time progressed Robbie began to realize
what was going on with Eli and the
result was that when he realized that
Eli was basically a villain that he was
a bad guy what Robbie did is he for the
most part maintained the powers of the
Ghost Rider while constantly trying to
suppress the influence of Eli and that's
basically always been his fate that's
the role that he plays the difference is
that in this story or at least in this
universe things didn't transpire that
exact same way they did insofar that Eli
bonded himself to taralli Reyes but
somewhere along the line the Venom
symbiote bonded itself to Ghost Rider
and the result is that it kind of
created this weird perfect being now
this also hinted the idea of spider-man
they referred to him as the spider guy
who died in the 1980s and so the
implication here is that the original
secret war story took place spider-man
was off fighting the Beyonder he
eventually came into contact
the Venom symbiote brought it back to
earthing it was just a costume that gave
him enhanced abilities eventually
realized the Venom symbiote was sentient
I'm an intern managed to cast it off
with the help of Reed Richards what this
story does is it introduces this idea
that presumably Spiderman died after we
got the Venom symbiote back or maybe the
Venom symbiote killed spider-man when it
bonded to Eddie Brock we don't really
know how all that transpired we just
know spider-man was dead the fact
remains that the Venom symbiote bonded
itself to Ghost Rider now the biggest
catch here is that the Venom symbiote
has historically always been weak to
fire and that begs the question how can
the Venom symbiote coincide alongside a
guy who's literally imbued with Hellfire
that questions never explicitly answered
we're just kind of given this around the
bush sort of explanation words like well
they work in tandem they manage to work
together and they manage to pull you
know pull it off and that kind of a
thing but at the end of the day what
really seems to happen here is it's
really more like an internal struggle
the Venom symbiote constantly wants to
escape but the Ghost Rider won't let it
so the Ghost Rider constantly keeps it
there that seems to be the implication
that's given but the idea here is that
Roddy Reyes himself is effectively a
background character instead of Robbie
Reyes constantly trying to suppress the
personality of Eli Morrow instead the
implication seems to be Eli Morrow is a
completely dominant personality and
Robbie Reyes is just kind of kept in the
background somewhere he has no real
control over his abilities and so the
results of this is we end up finding out
that none of this was part of the plan
instead what Calvin had done is he had
basically arranged for crossbones to
basically be given information about
which direction Calvin was going to be
going in where shield was going to take
him and then in turn grab that
information and just disperse it out to
the world that way and the ensuing chaos
presumably somebody somewhere would
successfully manage to destroy this
shield Caravan allowing Calvin to just
leave and so nobody would know that
Calvin orchestrated all this really
there would be no implication that he
was there now something else is really
given here which is actually kind of
cool is something called the penance
kiss now the penance kiss is not a
normal ability of Robbie Reyes it's not
something you're going to find in the
normal ghostwriter cards with Robbie
himself what a penance kiss does is it
basically allows Ghost Rider to examine
an individual to see if they are guilty
or if they're innocent if they're
considered to be guilty or at least how
he deems them to be guilty basically
meaning they're good guys and in turn
allows him to basically consume theirs
or their soul or what-have-you but it
basically turns them just into a husk of
a human being they have no soul they
have no spirit no essence they're just
organs functioning and that's it I mean
their mind is effectively gone and
that's exactly what happens with Calvin
he's basically destroyed and then he's
fed to the car Robbie Rhea's which is
actually really messed up the car
literally eats him which is we're just
kind of screwed up but in the middle of
all this he's basically whisked away
much than the same way that x-23 was he
literally teleported away we don't know
where he's teleported all we know is
that he's teleported and brought before
the minimized version of Captain America
essentially and of course it's basically
this idea that these different venom
Eyes characters are being brought
together by Captain America for some
unknown task we won't know until the
actual venom verse story kicks off
without being said guys we're gonna go
ahead and bring this video to an end
hit the fun little video fun little
thing you know talked about a venom eyes
Ghost Rider a pretty interesting little
scenario but yeah guys we're gonna go
ahead bring this video to an end if you
are new here to comments explain make
sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rod force you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
light and yeah I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]